Hey guys, I'm Nate, welcome back to the workshop.
Today we've got a few different experiments that a ton of people have asked to see
using our vacuum chamber. None of them were quite big enough to make a whole video about.
But we're gonna try combining three together and see if we get any cool results from it.
So the three things we're gonna be trying today... We're going to try putting bubble wrap in our vacuum
chamber, and sucking all the air out, see if the bubble expand, maybe pop.
We're gonna be trying putting a watermelon in, both the cut open varieties, and the completely sealed
up varieties. Obviously, we are going to be using a slightly smaller watermelon, since a whole one will
not fit in the chamber.
And then a large number of people also asked to see soap in the vacuum chamber.
And I wasn't sure if they were asking about bar soap or dish soap, so we're gonna try both.
Let's get started.
Ivory soap in a microwave is an experiment you may have seen before.
It weirdly expands and grows like some sort of grotesque monster...
...escaped from the deep. So I'm going to be trying Ivory soap as our bar soap in the vacuum chamber.
There's our Ivory soap after being microwaved and as soon as it cools down
you can see it starts shrinking quite a bit. We'll put this in the vacuum chamber, we'll see if anything happens to it.
Maybe it will expand the same way it does in the microwave. That's a result of either the heat
or the radiation hitting it.
We'll see what happens in the vacuum chamber.
It's sliding...?
I don't know if that counts as a result, but it's moving a little bit.
That could just be the vibration from the pump running.
Nope. I'm gonna say that a bar of soap in a vacuum is not exciting.
Just to block the soap and nothing happened to it.
Alright, well. Let's take the soap that we microwaved and put that in the vacuum chamber and see if that does anything?
Soap cloud here.
See a little bit of movement.
Interestingly, that movement is coming off of the block of soap that didn't really go anywhere in the microwave.
The part that was uncooked...
That's the part that started expanding a little bit.
Seems to have calmed down, though. It's not really going much more yet.
That was not much more exciting than our whole block of soap. You get a little bit of expansion.
Right down here, and I bet that collapses down a little as we reintroduce pressure, but for the most part...
...that wasn't very exciting.
Ivory soap is more entertaining to just put in the microwave; the vacuum chamber doesn't do as much.
Our bar soap didn't give us a great result, so let's move on to trying some dish soap.
Let's pour some off into a cup, put that in the vacuum chamber, see what happens.
Now there are quite a few bubbles suspended in that soap, so I bet those are gonna expand somewhat,
and we might get a nice foam effect as those bubbles grow and move out of the top.
And...I dunno, let's find out.
The bubbles are moving! They're already expanding!
A whole level of the soap is rising slightly in the cup as well.
Now it's rising not so slightly. Which is rising.
And we have blue foam.
See how long this will keep goin'!
We've got some really big bubbles down on the sides. Those are getting so big that they're rupturing.
Still got tons of tiny, tiny little bubbles with room to expand.
I might have to add pressure back in if it gets so high that it's gonna start filling the chamber all the way.
Think I am...
Woo!
That was just a tiny, tiny bit of air and just dropped it all down.
Pressure barely rose even a tiniest bit. It was still enough to just pop tons of bubbles.
Going back up for round two!
I suspect that I could be filling this thing and dropping pressure back in on and off for hours before I really got all of the
bubbles out of the soap the soap holds bubbles so well that I don't really think they're ever just gonna completely disappear
well
We definitely get a good result out of the liquid soap there are bubbles in it and more bubbles form as you
pull a vacuum
And then those bubbles just become soap bubbles and turn into foam and it really expands
Beautifully and want to add pressure, and it just all collapses this
Maybe that just turns back into regular soap
Moving on to our next experiment
Let's see what happens if we take this half watermelon throw it into our container and suck out all the air
Will it do anything? I don't know?
Bubbles kind of forming all over the surface of our watermelon
even on the green part of the rind
Has a lot of juice being pulled out of that watermelon?
Had some cracks forming too at this point of course a lot of the water that has seeped out is boiling and low pressure
All right
That definitely did something to our watermelon oh
Wow that changed it almost even more our vacuumed watermelon
scooped a little bit out of this and
See how it tastes
This tastes like watermelon it's not really any different not noticeably I
Want to try this again
I've got the other half of this watermelon
Let's cut it in half again, so we have more exposed surface area
and then I'll also keep a piece of it cut off so we can compare our before and we're after a a
lot of bubbling going on
It doesn't look like it's changing a whole lot at this point though
Without dark that turned. It's pretty impressive
So it doesn't look incredibly changed for the most part. It still just looks like a watermelon some of the colors
I think we definitely have some darker richer shades of red and
Maybe even it's brought out a little bit more of the white to give it a higher contrast
So here's our vacuum tank with water on
Vacuum chambers water
Mostly the same
I think we can see a little bit more
Fiber on the inside of the one that we've run through the vacuum chamber a little bit less on the other side
Let's do a taste test non vacuumed regular watermelon
Vacuum bottle
I can't tell the difference it's the same thing so it's doing something. I think it's just not doing a lot as
one final watermelon test let's take a whole
Sealed up watermelon put that in and pull a vacuum and see if it does anything
I rather doubt there will be a pressure difference great enough for the watermelon to crack or start leaking or anything like that
But there's only one way to be sure
All right pulling the vacuum on a whole watermelon three two one
I don't see any cracks or leaks or spots where it's popping open
Pretty much the same to me one other test though is I'm gonna open the valve that lets all the pressure flood in really quickly
And we'll see if there's any movement, maybe the watermelon has grown slightly as the depressurized around it
Let's see if it shrinks at all when I put the pressure back in oh
It did it did shrink it's not a big change
It doesn't do anything really crazy
But the watermelon definitely does grow in the vacuum and then shrink when we put the pressure back in
So I think that's pretty fun suppose now. We got to crack it open and see if it looks any different I bet it won't
How surprising it looks like a watermelon I
Don't really have a good sense of how much of this to use, but I don't know that looks
Wow looks like a pretty good amount
It's just a small piece
We'll probably move on to doing larger pieces later, but to start out. We'll use that
I think that'll really let us see what's going on with Mitch individual bubble all right here goes
It all tightened up as the bubbles like really filled their spot. Oh, I think a couple of them have started leaking
And they're all gone
Every single one is popped
All right, that was really entertaining now. Let's just try putting a whole bunch of what we're wrapping and once and see what happens
In this piece of the sheet pop them all ha ha ha ha
While they're all going off really fast like that it kind of sounds like popcorn popping in a frying pan or something
I think that's it. I think they've all popped
It's probably the most efficient way to
Waste large bubble-wrap just pops every single one try like this half a little roll
Squish that down in there now. This is rolled up tight so I don't know what its gonna
Do because the bubbles don't have as much space to expand
Let's find out
Oh tearing at the seams
The roll is pulled itself open
This bubble wrap roll comes perforated. So you can separate off just sheets about one foot long and
The pressure has just ripped it along those perforations
Alright, I think once you get to that pressure
It's just about all gone
Well there you have it bubble wrap watermelon and a couple of types of soap in a vacuum chamber
We got some fairly fun reactions the bubble wrap all expanded and then popped the watermelon just kind of leaked a little bit of juice
The bar soap wasn't very exciting
But the liquid soap really foamed and bubbled up quite a bit every one of these experiments were things that dozens
If not hundreds of people commented asking for us to do so guys
We are using your ideas if you've got something you want to see us, try let us know down in the comments below
Thanks for joining us for this experiment today and remember to come grab your hats shirts and other cool merch at the king of random
Calm see you there
Very weirdly powdery at this point
You right there the one who just watched this video to the end
You are the reason that we work so hard to make these videos. It's for people like you
Thank you very kindly for being as supportive as you are. You keep watching the videos we'll keep making more
Thanks For watching! Remember to Subscribe!